[Música]
en directo a América hablamos de
economía y por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero Juan Pablo lucumí
Juan Pablo bienvenido Buenas noches
Valentina Buenas noches vamos a iniciar
con un tema bastante interesante El
Banco Central de Turquía tiene
presidenta Quién es así es ya usted lo
adelantaba se trata de erkan la primera
mujer en dirigir el Banco Central luego
de que el presidente recién electo
recepta gildogan la hubiese nominado
para el cargo vamos a responder entonces
a la pregunta de quién es ella pues
tiene 41 años naciones Estambul de Padre
ingeniero y madre maestra de matemáticas
y física asistió a una de las mejores
escuelas estatales de Turquía y se
graduó como la segunda mejor de su clase
estudió ingeniería industrial en la
universidad de bogasisi una de las
universidades más prestigiosas de
Turquía y obtuvo un doctorado en
investigación de operaciones e
ingeniería financiera en 2006
recientemente estudió en Harvard y
Stanford bueno Y también se sabe que
tiene una larga trayectoria el mundo
financiero con diferentes empresas y
entidades valentinas si le parece vamos
a revisar Entonces cuál ha sido esa
carrera pues con las finanzas
encontramos que se unió al banco de
inversión Global goldman sacks en 2005 y
ya en 2011 la nombraron directora
general del mismo más tarde en 2014 se
unió al público y se convirtió en
codirectora ejecutiva del mismo en 2021
Esto fue recientemente un banco que
también nos ha dado tema de que hablar
por todo el tema de la quiebra ha tenido
una larga trayectoria en Wall Street y
el dato más reciente es que en junio de
2022 fue nombrada directora ejecutiva de
briston una compañía de inversión y
finanzas inmobiliarias con sede en Nueva
York lo que quiere decir que está
bastante preparada para el cargo en
Turquía y veremos Que decida no Bueno
vamos ahora a hablar de Disney Disney
hizo un anuncio que algunos analistas
han calificado de desesperado de qué se
trata así es Valentina
que es el servicio de streaming indio
operado por Disney entertainment anunció
que ofrecerá gratuita de torneos de
Cricket en India en dispositivos móviles
el anuncio es sumamente determinante
para la compañía porque recordemos que
el Cricket es el juego más popular en la
nación más poblada del mundo y cuenta
con hasta 700 millones de usuarios que
consumen estos contenidos en sus
teléfonos inteligentes Disney dijo que
la oferta gratuita llegará a más de 540
millones de usuarios que usan sus
teléfonos inteligentes y que esta medida
se hacía para que todos tengan acceso a
los partidos la decisión la han
calificado de desesperada porque Disney
antes tenía los derechos digitales para
la India Premier League una de las
propiedades deportivas anuales más
lucrativas del mundo pero su competencia
en el país hablamos de Cinema gastó 2,9
millones de dólares para obtener esos
derechos luego de que lanzó de forma
gratuita a la plataforma la transmisión
ahí ya podemos ver una de las razones de
Por qué Disney toma esta decisión los
partidos de Cricket sin embargo seguirán
siendo pagados cuando accede a través de
televisión o a través del sitio web lo
que quiere decir que solamente para
dispositivos móviles Bueno pues de
Disney vamos a pasar a hablar de otra de
las grandes plataformas y es Netflix
seguro que usted tiene de las dos
plataformas ahora hablamos de Netflix
porque las suscripciones diarias a esta
plataforma en Estados Unidos se
incrementaron recientemente luego de que
la compañía estableció el 23 de mayo la
limitación para compartir contraseñas de
las cuentas una práctica que también es
muy común de nosotros los usuarios
compartir las las contraseñas de estas
plataformas según los cálculos de la
compañía se registraron al menos 100.000
suscriptores diarios el 26 de mayo y el
27 de ese mismo mes unos días después de
la limitación y se espera que sigan
saltando estas cifras Netflix había
estimado que más de 100 millones de
hogares habían proporcionado sus
credenciales de inicio de sesión a las
personas fuera de sus hogares bajo las
nuevas reglas los usuarios
estadounidenses pueden agregar un
miembro de sus hogares que esté fuera de
sus hogares solo con una tarifa
adicional de 8 dólares por todo un
cambio drástico en la compañía que en
algún momento tuiteó que compartir la
contraseña es igual al amor Juan Pablo Y
usted sigue compartiendo su contraseña o
ya sacó su cuenta personal no debo sacar
la contraseña Y ser uno de esos
suscriptores Bueno vamos ahora con Los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
bueno empezamos por nuestra región
porque las bolsas en América Latina
cerraron con ganancias todas con una
leve subida para un Cierre en su mayoría
en números positivos en pantalla vemos
las ganancias de los principales
indicadores de México Argentina y Brasil
Europa en cambio cerró también en
pérdidas este viernes movidas por los
datos de inflación de las principales
economías y luego de que se reportara
que la Unión Europea entró en recesión
técnica un tema que estuvimos revisando
el día de ayer Estados Unidos en cambio
cerró en positivo con sus tres
principales indicadores reportando leves
alzas que no llegaron a un 0,20% y
cerramos con la cifra del día son los
3,17 millones de turistas extranjeros
que recibió México en abril lo que
representa un incremento de un 3,5%
respecto al mes del año anterior pues
Tendremos que hacer nosotros parte de
esa cifra y viajar a México prontamente
Así es Juan Pablo Muchas gracias por
esta ampliación económica ahora con
mucho más Valentina bueno Y nosotros los
dejamos con Rosa Pérez mateu que ya
llega con una semana en el mundo